-Jay Pharoah, it is your turn.
Won't you step up here,
pull the mic?
Let's see what you get.
-Let's go.
Let's go.
-I don't know, y'all.
I don't know.
-You've got this.
-Alright.
-Let's see.
[ Beeping ]
[ Indistinct ]
-Hey, come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wheel of Musical Impressions!
-♪ Wheel of
Musical Impressions ♪
♪ Wheel of
-Okay. What are we doing?
-Jay, this is good.
For this one,
you're gonna get an artist.
-Okay.
-You're gonna have to sing
a song while doing
an impression of them.
Let's see what it will be.
-Oh, man.
[ Beeping ]
-Alright, the song first.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Oh, my God.
-I'm stressed.
-"Drops of Jupiter."
-As Prince.
-No way! Yes!
-Y'all, y'all trust me a lot.
Okay. Okay.
-Jay, take your mark over there.
Jam Band, please give us
something funky.
-Here we go.
[ Funky music playing ]
-♪ Oh ♪
-Hey!
-♪ Ow ♪
♪ Ah ♪
♪ Now that she's back
in the atmosphere ♪
♪ With drops of Jupiter
in her hair, oh ♪
♪♪
♪ She acts like summer
and walks like rain ♪
♪ Reminds me that
there's a time to change, ow ♪
-So good.
-He's amazing, right?
-I can't!
-♪ Since the return
of her stay on the moon ♪
♪ She listens like spring
and she talks like June ♪
♪♪
Get up!
♪ But tell me,
did you sail across the sun? ♪
♪ Did you make it
to the Milky Way ♪
♪ To see the lights all faded ♪
♪ And that Heaven
is overrated? ♪
♪ Tell me,
did Venus blow your mind? ♪
♪ Was it everything you wanted
to find, and did you miss me ♪
♪ While you were
looking for yourself, uh ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God!
-♪ Did you fall
from a shooting star? ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
I got a question.
♪ Did you fall
from a shooting star? ♪
♪ Oh ♪
One more time. One more time.
-♪ Did you fall
from a shooting star? ♪
Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God!
Oh, my God!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh!
-Oh-ho!
-Yo! A standing ovation!
-Standing.
-For Jay Pharoah!
-He's so good. He's so good.
-Wow.
-That was so good.
-So good.
-Wow.
-Amazing.
-That was incredible.
-You nailed -- Come on.
Jay Pharoah right there,
ladies and gentlemen.
-Whoo!
-Wow.
-You're so good!